Nó hay ngay ra giáp tổ quốc trong tiên, được con sớm phim đã có suyên thuộc hơn một tý đồng, con số khá quan với một bộ phim hà nhạc.
Những thực phim một lần nữa mang tới cho khán giả biết bảo cũng bật cảm xúc cũng như chuyển tâm mạnh nè về lọc yêu nước.
Phần hấp dẫn nhất của phim đã các tiên mục khi ngay đẹp trong con sớm, xuống người xem một dự sống lại khóc ký trạm để tình yêu nước và lọc được hào dân tập.
Môn người đi lại tiếp hợp với âm thành, hình anh chưa lợp như biến sạm phim thành một có sớm thật tụi.
Thì hả giả trong sạm cũng phải cơ, bố tay, khổ hỗ, hoa giảm hát theo, mang tới một con ký hùng trái, hào hứng sôi đậu trưa tình có trong giảm phim.
Chúng tôi mong bốn là cái chiến trình tổ quốc trong phim mà không chỉ dừng lại ở một cái điểm giận rất là bụng lộ trên sân bị đình mới hơn mong mề ngàn tham dự.
Nếu chúng ta có thể kéo dài câu chuyện thì cái sự lan toàn này nó sẽ để bởi mọi gia đình.
Và trong một quần thế gián lâu hất, trên toàn quốc đến với tình miệp phương.
Tình người rất mong môn mọi người sẽ ủng hộ bộ phim và sẽ mọi lợp được trải qua cái trải nghiệp rất tự hào.
Sẽ cũng hát lên đến với hát cách mạng rất là thị liên như vậy.
Mình hợp lại những giải phút thang hoài nhất của tình ữ nước.
Tân cả một bộ phim, tổ quốc trong tim, tờ con sất phim đang xấu bức phát triển tiếp theo trong trễ lực trên thông bình hoạc của báo niên dân,
mở giọc hành trình của con sơ cuộc sà, tổ quốc trong tim tư sân khấu tự tế để mạng giọc và không sân cập đồng.
Tác phẩm thiết tư suy đổi mới, các đường hay hoa giữa giả trị bất hoa, chứ nghiệp sả hội, công nghệ hiệp đại trong biểu sây dựth hệ sinh thái sản phẩm trên thông, bất hoa, nghiệp thuật bình bưới.
Tại vì tất sĩ sống nước lại, tất sông, tất cả đại khỏe khỏe đấy, trong khả mà anh trình, kênh những nhận chạm đầu tiên, sọ đến những khu dây thang hoa nhất và nơi tất cả mọi người cùng quyết màa lại được vời nhau.
Anh trình đấy chúng tôi không thể kè được tất cả, chỉ là một phần nào đó, nhưng nhiều tổ điện anh sẽ giúp chúng ta cảm nhận tất cả nhiều tổ này, tất cả những dựng chạm này, với những tóc nhìn rất dương.
Để từ đây chúng ta cảm nhận rằng, giả trị của phố vương phân hoa, đang được tình bước, đang được tình bước, các dựng chạm, và trong những dệng chút tôi, và rất nhiều những người cho vời đang làm.
Với ý nghĩa đó, tổ quốc trong tiên, tự khó sất tiêm, được ki vọng sẽ trở thành một dấu móc trong sông trầy vân hoa Việt Nam hình đại, có phần lần toại tình thần yêu nước, bằng un lữ của ông nhà, nể thuật và tiện anh.